big budget letdowns Indie flicks that
didn't hit their Mark and self-indulgent
passion projects there are plenty of
reasons why movies bomb at the box
office and here are a few of the biggest
Duds this year
Robert Eggers is an Eclectic filmmaker
best known for having a unique surreal
style having written and directed some
truly visually striking horror films in
the past such as 2015's the witch led by
Anya tiller joy and 2019's the
lighthouse starring Willem Dafoe and
Robert Pattinson 2022's the Northman
positions itself as an epic historical
action film set in the 10th Century
during the reign of the Vikings the
Northman itself follows Viking Warrior
and disgraced prince amleth who seeks
revenge on his evil Uncle fionir the
brotherless for killing his father King
arvindel years later amlith returns to
his homeland as an adult to avenge his
family's honor the film also gets great
performances from the likes of Nicole
Kidman Bjork as well as Defoe and Taylor
Joy Based on the original Legend that
inspired Hamlet it's a stunning visual
treat to witness on screen especially
the climactic fight between amalth and
fulner in the middle of an erupting
volcano Alexander Skarsgard as always is
also a compelling screen presence and
leads the film with very few words or
Expressions unfortunately following a
sad history of movies starring Skarsgard
that bombed such as 2012's Battleship
and 2016's The Legend of Tarzan the film
was sent to Valhalla in shame at the box
office in the end it ended up making
just over 69 million dollars on an
almost 100 million dollar budget
Bros is admittedly not the first
mainstream Studio lgbtq Plus romantic
comedy with films like 1996's The
Birdcage starring Robin Williams as well
as 1999's But I'm a Cheerleader with
Natasha Leone preceding it however Bros
was nonetheless still the first released
in a while especially at this scale and
budget costing approximately 25 million
dollars however it is the first major
film to start in entirely lgbtq plus
cast Bros is directed by Nick stahler
and is written by and starring comedian
Billy Eichner best known for his Funny
or Die show Billy on the Street the plot
follows ikner as an abrasively neurotic
and opinionated art curator named Bobby
Lieber who's helping to put together an
lgbtq plus themed Art Exhibit in New
York City he also loves or at least says
he loves being single and using Grindr
for quick hookups while living a
solitary and independent life that is
until he meets Aaron Shepard who seems
like Bobby's complete opposite can they
make their relationship work watch the
film to find out which we recommend
despite great critical reception the
film made less than half of its budget
back at the box office which is a shame
Beyond its historical importance as an
lgbtq plus film it's also just a very
funny heartwarming and achingly human
romantic comedy hopefully it'll get a
renewed evaluation soon
the Disney CG animated light year is a
spin-off film based on the heroic
Spaceman toy character Buzz Lightyear
from the iconic Toy Story franchise in
the original 1995 film Buzz Lightyear is
introduced as the newest hottest toy of
the season with lights projectiles and
the ability to do karate chops it's
clear that in the universe of the Pixar
Animation Studios films Buzz is the main
character of a fictional hugely
successful sci-fi Adventure franchise
that spans movies cartoons and Comics to
infinity and beyond
Disney then decided to produce light
year an adaptation of the fictional
character that the Buzz Lightyear toy is
based on in the Toy Story Universe
instead of Tim Allen Buzz is voiced by
Captain America star Chris Evans the
concept of light year is not that
complicated but it did cause confusion
with some fans especially after Evan's
now Infamous tweet describing the film
and just to be clear this isn't Buzz
Lightyear the toy this is the origin
story of the human Buzz Lightyear that
the toy is based on there was the 2001
TV series Buzz Lightyear of Star Command
where Buzz was voiced by Patrick
Warburton it only ran for just one
season sadly the show doesn't seem to
share much if any continuity with the
film light year didn't go into infinity
or Beyond at the box office making under
120 million dollars domestically
compared to its 200 million dollar plus
price tag even the worldwide gross 220
million dollars doesn't take into
account the exorbitant advertising
budget
another Disney CG animated film that
turned out to be a failure at the box
office is the adventure story Strange
World it costs the studio approximately
200 million dollars but only netted a
quarter of that earning under 55 million
dollars globally which is a shame
because it's a fun film that even got
favorable reviews the story follows
super scientist Searcher clade whose
famous Adventurer father Jager clade
went missing years ago on a dangerous
Expedition however in the present day
the entire world is now in trouble due
to an unexplained ecological disaster
and Searcher is the only one who can
save the day by traveling into the
eponymous Strange World underneath the
planet not only does Searcher find out
that his estranged father is still alive
and has been living in this strange
place for decades but that his son Ethan
has snuck onto the mission as well
luckily Ethan finds a way to bridge the
gap between the two generations of
clades while saving the world in the
process the film is worth watching for
its unique visuals both in the diesel
Punk designs of its chips and Tech but
also in the strange creatures and
environment of the world itself not only
that but there's some great and
unambiguous lgbtq plus representation
and depressioned and nuanced
environmental message as well director
Roland Emerick is best known for his big
budget disaster movies such as
Independence Day and the day after
tomorrow where entire cities explode as
All-Star casts trade quips amidst the
destruction while emmerich has done some
other types of films such as the
Shakespeare conspiracy film Anonymous
disaster films are his bread and butter
meanwhile his sci-fi disaster epic
moonfall probably contains the most
devastating threat to the world so far
because it is literally about the moon
falling to Earth the film follows
disgraced astronaut Brian Harper who is
recruited by his former colleague
josinda Joe Fowler to go on a desperate
space mission along with a conspiracy
theorist Casey Houseman who first finds
out about the moonfall their goal is to
discover the cause of it and if there's
any way to stop it when he under the
moon is out of orbit while the film's
premise is of course ridiculous that's
not a problem for an Emerick film The
reason people flock to his disaster
films is the over-the-top and explosive
destruction scenes and moonfall mostly
delivers this includes a scene where New
York City gets entirely sucked up by the
moon's gravitational pull unfortunately
despite those aforementioned VFX
sequences it crashed and burned harder
than the moon in the film did making a
little over 67 million dollars on a
nearly 150 million dollar budget even
worse the film ends on a preposterously
sequel baiting note with Houseman and
aliens that won't ever come to fruition
the superhero action horror film morbius
is part of Sony's non-mcu Spider-Man
villains without Spider-Man universe
which also includes the two Tom
hardy-led Venom films unfortunately
unlike those films morbius was a
financial disaster barely making its
budget back domestically not accounting
for the massive marketing push it was
given however if you were to listen to
the internet Sony's
book adaptation was a huge commercial
success and a critical darling even
getting praise from The anti-marvel
Martin Scorsese obviously none of that
is true but the memes that the film's
box office failure generated which
includes the infamous its morbin
timeline that didn't even actually
appear in the film itself LED Sony to
somehow re-release the film back into
theaters with little embarrassingly
referencing the aforementioned meme in
real life that re-release turned out to
be even more of a financial failure
making morbius one of the rare movies
with the distinction of bombing twice
though JK Rowling continues to court
controversy around her political beliefs
her Harry Potter franchise is still
highly profitable there's the
continually packed Wizarding World of
Harry Potter attraction at Universal
Studios in Los Angeles and Florida in
upcoming open World adventure video game
called Hogwarts Legacy and Warner
Brothers Discovery CEO David sasloff
confirming that Harry Potter will be a
priority moving forward one of the only
areas where the success hasn't fully
translated is the latest Fantastic
Beasts spin-off film the latest
installment Fantastic Beasts the secrets
of Dumbledore made just over 95 million
dollars domestically at the box office
on a 200 million dollar budget even
accounting for Global takings it still
made less than half of what 2016's
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
pulled in the Fantastic Beasts films are
set between 1926 and 1932 and are meant
to follow Magi zoologist newt's
Commander as he tries to capture and
study magical creatures who found
themselves in the Muggle World however
during this time the dark Wizard and
precursor to the main series villain
Voldemort Geller Grindelwald is rising
to power this on top of the introduction
of young Albus Dumbledore means that
newt's Adventures takes a back seat to
the point that he becomes a supporting
character in the franchise Bob's Burgers
is an animated sitcom on Fox that
debuted in 2011. it stars each John
Benjamin is Bob Belcher the perpetually
poor but extremely talented owner of the
eponymous Bob's Burgers restaurant which
is also run by the rest of the Belcher
family who all live in an apartment
above the diner this includes his
lovable and anarchic wife Linda his
awkward oldest teen daughter Tina his
creative and eccentric middle son Gene
and his rambunctious Troublemaker with a
heart of gold youngest daughter Louise
throughout the show the refreshingly
working-class family interacts with many
memorable Supporting Cast members such
as the cheerfully greedy eye-patched
landlord Mr Fish odor after running for
over a decade it was decided that the
belchers deserved the big screen
treatment which makes sense as many
animated series turned feature films
have had great success such as South
Park bigger longer uncut Beavis and
Butthead to America and The Simpsons
Movie among others unfortunately the
Bob's Burgers movie wasn't able to catch
on with audiences outside of the
television screen despite being well
received critically the film made less
than its budget not accounting for
marketing at least it keeps in line with
Bob's specialty Burgers they're
critically well regarded but failed to
bring in the money they deserve stop we
have to sell some burgers today right
yes we got four days to pay the bank
that's true come on okay fine but only
because we're desperate
the explosive action spy Thriller the
355 boasts a can't miscast of amazing
actresses including Jessica Chastain
Penelope Cruz fan bing bing Diane Kruger
and Lupita Nyong'o all playing
International agents trying to save the
world from terrorists directed by Simon
kinberg the 355 follows a pretty generic
albeit serviceable plot both spies from
different countries struggling to trust
and work together and stop a global
threat the direction is surprisingly
competent with relatively fun action
sequences whatever flaws the film has it
at least seems clear that the Stars put
in a lot of work with the stunts and
fight choreography however despite the
all-star cast and competent action
scenes the movie failed spectacularly at
the box office making just over 25
million dollars against a 75 million
dollar budget hopefully this doesn't
deter Hollywood from making more
female-led action films as tons of
filled spy flicks starring men have
existed over the years and the industry
never seems to think audiences hate
seeing male action heroes
the Australian auteur George Miller has
had inexpensive and eclectic film career
over the years for one he's The
Mastermind behind the Mad Max franchise
which besides being awesome action films
in their own right pretty much dictated
the aesthetic of post-apocalyptic genre
movies ever since however he's also
responsible for writing and directing
other popular films that wouldn't
necessarily seem to fit his Uber at
first glance such as babe pig in the
city and the CG animated Happy Feet
films
[Music]
that'll do after Miller's decades later
Mad Max reboot Mad Max Fury Road became
a smash critical and Commercial Success
he was given a blank check to do
whatever passion project he wanted so of
course Miller zagged instead of zigged
and decided to write and direct the
visually stunning 3 000 years of longing
the film itself is a surreal fantasy
romance between a magical genie and a
lonely woman named Alessia to whom he
Regals Tales from his past while the
film got mixed to positive reviews it
unfortunately only made a third of its
60 million dollar budget back hopefully
Miller's wish for another success will
come true soon as he revs up to write
and direct the furiosa prequel as his
next project
[Music]